vous aussi c'est votre maman qui vous a
dit que khaled était votre votre papa
oui ça a pris tellement la dira qu'elle
très vite - iliad avec un jour du 26 ans
l'accord à quel âge me bats depuis ma
naissance j'ai envie de me l'a jamais
caché en fait il ya des photos belge
apporter justement oui je peux battre
dit ma mère que c'est une groupie
d'accord je suis lent 95 ses écrits de
sa main 91 à bonneuil voilà des des
souvenirs de ma mère et de mon père qui
vivait ensemble amoureusement d'accord
qui m'ont vu dans un amour véritable et
voilà il ya eu beaucoup de rumeurs
venant de sa femme justement qui s'est
amusé inverse m'invectiver telle
célérité l'histoire de votre maman et de
khaled on fait alors ils se sont
rencontrés quand il arrivait en france
de base il a une histoire assez
particulière qu'est ce qui est venu en
france sans parler un mot de français
mais mme aïcha il la chantait en
phonétique ouais c'était parle de
goldman et en gros elle a un peu aidés
en fait tout simplement celle qui lui a
présenté les bonnes personnes qui l'a
branché dans des cabarets au début où il
se produisait elle avait un peu un rôle
d'agent officieux on va dire d'accord
mais quand il a commencé un peu à
grimper voilà il a rencontré sa femme
actuelle qui s'appelle samir hadji amis
et cette femme là en fait au début
ma mère de ce que ma mère m'a dit
maintenant est décédé depuis trois ans
il y avait des contacts débuts en fait
ils étaient prêts à venir me voir de
temps en temps etc voilà et puis du jour
au lendemain en fait c'est comme si
j'avais été rayé de sa vie c'est à dire
que bah déjà j'avais pas été reconnu il
a fallu faire une lourde de bataille
judiciaire que ma mère a mené avec brio
d'ailleurs on a fait des tests adn ça
salivaire constaté par le juge pénal
aurait donc alors à partir de ce moment
là j'ai porté son nom j'ai été reconnu
vous savez tous reconnu la wii c'est ça
mais d'ailleurs souvent il ya méprise là
dessus mais j'ai eu c'est bien que vous
leur disiez voilà vous avez été vous a
été reconnue vous êtes bien le fils de
khaled c'est ça j'ai eu plusieurs
fois essayé de contacter puisque ben
maintenant je suis journaliste et à
l'époque je travaillais déjà avec la
radio beur fm ça m'arrivait d'aller à
certains de ses concerts j'étais allé à
un concert de lui un jour j'ai ma
première garde à vue en fait c'est un
concert de l'ue de quoi j'étais dans mon
stage de 3e à beur fm voilà la radio
maghrébine lutte en colère parce que je
vais bien tous les poids et gelé qui se
bat voilà bah c'est sa famille et bat en
gros je devais l'interviewer avec un
journaliste mais rien à voir progresser
mon travail c'est là où je suis
aujourd'hui c'est grâce à moi et pas
monde solidaire dacquois et
ben quand il a vu que c'était moi en
fait et après une autre sortie ayant un
mec sa sécurité qui m'a dit viens viens
on va t'amener voir ton père du coup
j'ai suivi trop bien trop contents et
tous et au final je me retrouve dehors
d'art une pièce qu'une source que je
peux pas ouvrir est là j'ai commencé je
vais casser une mercedes et je finis en
garde à vue derrière j'ai un peu saccagé
la salle de concert à l'époque ça avait
fait du bruit il y avait bryan palumbo
une de vos chroniqueuse bien sûr kim
avait reconnu que d'aller lé patron du
public elle vient nous voir c'est une
amie voilà
qui avait un peu raconté l'histoire dans
ce magazine qui m'avait contacté
d'ailleurs et ça m'avait permis déjà de
mettre en lumière cette histoire et mais
le plus grave en fait actuellement c'est
que ben j'aimais mes soeurs en fait
qu'ils n'ont pu réussir à me contacter
et enfin certaines là la plus grande
sarah à m'avait contacté au début
j'entends une voix un peu comme dans
scream sur mon téléphone après les
articles ouais donne ton de famine un
mois je le donne et ooyala j'entends une
voix toute douce ouais bah écoutes je ta
soeur moi j'habite avec eux
et puis elle m'a parlé des maltraitances
qui a subi sept sa mère et c'est vrai
que là je n'ai jamais appris mon
existence en fait pour et que bas elle
m'a donné une adresse du coup un rendez
vous qui l'avez lui avec sa femme du
coup ma belle-mère que j'embrasse aussi
d'ailleurs d'accord et
et ben là j'arrive je le croise dans la
rue j'ai eu des sales usa et lui dit je
te connais pas il fallait qu'elle sait
très bien ce wiki et 30 secondes après
ce mets à m'insulter à parler comme la
dernière des racailles ou l'endroit même
insulter de tous les noms maman moi même
voilà et
depuis plus tard elle a viré ma plus
grande soeur qui est actuellement à la
rue en fait simplement et en même temps
elle s'amuse à amman une campagne en
fait de calomnies envers moi dans le
sens où elle fait des statuts instagram
sur la page de mon père parce qu'il n'a
pas le droit de toucher un téléphone des
faits des story sur sa part instagram en
mettant mon seul et unique fils vous
souhaitons une bonne année sachant que
c'est un petit qui ne lui ressemble pas
du tout d'ailleurs d'accord et
et m et des trucs genre bah sa mère
c'est un résidu de préservatifs avec un
groupe i machines c'est une femme mère
de physique quand même ça et elle
s'amuse à utiliser la page officielle de
son mari qui est quand même une star
internationale moi j'aime pas ce qu'il
fait mais faut reconnaître les choses et
il utilise sa sa page en fait pour faire
des trucs comme ça c'est puéril et c
voilà du coup je viens ici pour mettre
les choses au clair je suis en train de
déchirer le conducteur en même temps
vous avez vous avez essayé de le revoir
ou la cei pour vous c'est oui ben
régulièrement j'ai même son numéro de
téléphone à samira du coup que j'essaie
d'appeler régulièrement avec des numéros
différents calibres bien que fort il
veut pas entendre parler je pense que si
mais qu'il est
contraint de eyl enfin c'est ça il est
sous influence soit sous emprise pensé
qu' il regrette oui très certainement
j'ai des échos de ses amis de ma
grand-mère aussi car sa mère je vais
avoir régulièrement ce que lui ne fait
pas d'ailleurs mais est elle même à la
pas de nouvelles de lui alors que vous
avez oublié de lui faire passer
peut-être un courrier parce que
peut-être que par écrit n'a pas le droit
d'avoir
c'est incroyable on est dans une
situation vraiment où il est battu j'ai
porté plainte contre cette femme ça